When you first start looking through a microscope
at microorganisms, it’s very obvious that
each little cell is its own thing.
But then, as time goes on, and you start to
understand their relationships and their dependence
on each other, and also everything’s dependence
on them, each microbe starts to feel like
a piece of some much broader, even global
organism.
And of course, species of all kinds and sizes
have their ecological impacts.
And this actually becomes much more obvious
when you make that ecosystem less global by,
say, putting it in a little box.
And you might have seen one of these boxes
recently...maybe in your home, or at a restaurant,
or the doctor's office.
We are talking, of course, about aquariums.
This tank is just one of those tanks at a
mall aquarium store.
It's got some reefs and some fishes swimming
around, living in full display for people
passing by.
But just give it a moment...just a few seconds.
And there.
That is the disembodied hand of an aquarium
shop worker who probably went to work expecting
the usual aquarium shop business, until James,
our master of microscopes, came in and asked
if he could please have some water from the
tank.
Science is always a team effort, and fortunately,
this shop worker was a willing collaborator,
searching around for biofilm and other bits
from the tank in response to various requests
thrown his way.
Of course, there are plenty of macroscopic
animals in the aquarium to admire.
Have you ever wanted to see what a starfish
looks like when you're really up close?
Yeah. I mean, of course you have.
But the real focus of this expedition wasn’t
the fishes or the large invertebrates that
we can clearly see with our own eyes.
What we want to see is what else is in that tank.
This question is actually pretty important
for any aquarium you might want to set up
at home.
Sure, you might be most excited about the
fish.
But fish waste is full of ammonia, which can
accumulate to toxic levels if left unchecked.
In nature, microbes play an essential role
in the nitrogen cycle, including taking extremely
stable atmospheric nitrogen and turning it
into nutrients like these Trichodesmium do,
or by consuming nitrogenous waste.
To make sure that aquatic ecosystems have
the same cleaning abilities built in, people
install bio filters that contain nitrogen-consuming
bacteria in their aquariums.
It’s sort of like building wastewater treatment
into the artificial ecological neighborhood.
And beyond the basic care of keeping tanks,
scientists have been studying the microbial
composition of aquariums to explore all sorts
of questions.
One group collected tank water from seven
Rhode Island pet shops to examine the diversity
of microbial communities between them, finding
potential sources of pathogens that might
require further study.
Another group observed that freshwater aquarium
bio filters are dominated more by ammonia-oxidizing
archaea than they are by bacteria.
There are, of course, also large aquariums.
Like very large.
So large you have to drive out to visit them
so you can stand in awe.
And yes, scientists have been studying the
microbiomes of these large tanks too.
This includes a study of the Ocean Voyager
exhibit in Georgia, one of the largest aquariums
in the United States, where 14 months of tracking
the microbial community of the exhibit revealed
a surprising dynamic and changing community
despite the relative stability of the water
itself.
Just for reference, the Ocean Voyager exhibit
contains about 6.3 million gallons of artificial
seawater, and it houses very cool, odd animals
including the blacktip reef shark, the longcomb
sawfish, and the porcupine ray.
In contrast, the mall aquarium has a lot less
water in it, and the fish are not quite as varied.
But fortunately, we don’t need millions
of gallons of water
to find fascinating ecological diversity
We just need a microscope.
So we were pretty impatient to see what was
in that carefully obtained, mall tank water.
One of the first organisms that caught our
attention was foraminifera, this kind of conch
shell-looking thing.
Foraminifera, or forams for short,
are protists, and they can be found living
all over the ocean, both in terms of depth
and geographical location.
There are around 4,000 species of forams around
the world, of which we found only a handful
in this sample.
Their shells come in different shapes and
are made up of different material depending
on what species they are.
Now forams may look innocuous, but they've
been around for over 500 million years.
And with all those forams living and dying
over that long period, their shells have built
up on the deep ocean floor, accumulating to
the point where in death, they’re practically
a geological entity.
In turn, the chemical composition of their
shells has helped us better understand how
our oceans and climate have changed over millions
of years.
But while we were watching our new foram friends,
something else came along.
You can see it here, that long, thin line
snaking between the magnified sand grains.
It looks like a worm, but we think it’s
actually a Tracheloraphis, and I do not know
if we’re pronouncing that correctly, a mysterious
single-celled organism.
It's difficult to find a lot of information
on Tracheloraphis, probably because it’s
been difficult to culture in a lab for further
study.
Even filming it turned out to be a challenge.
The slide we were watching it on had too much
sand and debris in it for us to get a good
recording.
So we tried moving it over to a new slide,
taking off the coverslip and using a micropipette
to grab it.
Except that once we removed the coverslip,
that little guy just disappeared!
It took 3 hours to find it and prepare it
in this sample, but it was worth it for this
close up view of just how weird this unicellular
organism is.
What else did we find?
An amoeba spreading against microbial fauna
as its own internal crystals sparkle, like
an opening in tree branches that give way
to a galaxy.
There also long cyanobacteria stalks, the
idling dinoflagellates, the stunning trichodesmium
filaments, and this ciliate who seemed to
not quite know what it wanted to be doing.
I know that feel, buddy.
And all of this from some scoops taken from
a mall aquarium...all of these organisms make
those clear boxes of glass not just a storage
tank for some pretty fish, but a living ecosystem
with millions of organisms all depending on
each other to turn the basics of chemistry
into the majesty of life.
Thank you for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And if you like this show, who you really
want to thank are these people whose names
are on the screen right now, our patrons on
Patreon who make it possible for us to search
through grains of sand for hours so that we
can get a good picture of a weird micobe.
Thank you for indulging with us and allowing
us to indulge in this curiosity.
If you want to see more from our Master of
Microscopes James, check out Jam & Germs on
Instagram
And if you want to see more from us, you can
find us at youtube.com/microcosmos